oh my god this is so cool comes together
huh a few years back I got excited about
the Iron Man movie and the first one
came out as soon as I saw the first
trailer you know it was probably a lot
of people excited about something to do
with comic books or Robert Downey jr.
for me the real star was the suit and as
soon as it showed up on screen you know
I figured I had to have one by the time
I was done I end up with a pretty good
facsimile of the screen-used suit the
next really big one was my ed-209
replica so it's a life-size copy of the
bad guy droid from the original Robocop
films in the 1980s anybody who would try
to limit themselves to just one way of
doing something is going to really shut
down a lot of possibilities I've really
become sort of a jack-of-all-trades so
I'll be making things out of metal I'll
be making things in a plastic whether
it's styrene or acrylic or anything else
really
you know vacuum formed or just heat
formed and forged I'll find myself
tooling leather just as likely as you
know laying up fiberglass it really just
runs the whole spectrum of any kind of
method of fabrication you can come up
with at some point will find its way in
the projects that I'm working on just
about everything that I use was designed
for something else so either it was made
to be used as an adhesive or it was made
for construction materials I spend a lot
of time looking at anything that I run
across trying to think of how it can be
essentially abused and turned to my own
purposes in between all of that I also
find plenty of time to screw around in
the workshop and build things for me and
my friends it's really difficult for me
to decide exactly you know on a process
for determining what's worth making and
what's
worth making way I usually do it is I'll
see something that I really like whether
it's from a video game or a movie or TV
show and I'll make it a point to ignore
the initial impulse to jump right in and
start building something right away if
six or seven months pass and I still am
in love enough with the thing to make it
happen then there's a pretty good chance
that I actually like it enough to see a
project all the way through from start
to finish
this one
tends to be maintained in some sort of
like display ready shape
I also did another project about
characters from a game called Warhammer
40,000 they're the giant Space Marines
that I made if you put me in it normally
I'm five foot seven and by the time the
whole suit strapped together it puts me
at just about seven foot eight if
somebody had asked me 20 years ago where
I wanted to be now what I'd told them
was I just kind of want to have a
workshop with a bunch of people I like
hanging out with and make cool stuff and
essentially it's what I'm doing so yeah
it might be cooler if all of a sudden
you know one of my creations was the
star of the feature film but it would
still just be me with a group of guys
that I like hanging out with making cool
stuff